안녕하세요. 기술로트 알렉입니다.
AI 시대에 꼭 알아야 되는 기술들 지금 계속 말씀드리고 있습니다.
아키텍처 인데요. 이번에 제가 이렇게 좀 표현을 해봤습니다.
사람은 구조를 설계하고 AI가 개발하고 구축한다.
뭐 지금 이제는 틀린 말은 아니죠.
물론 여기까지도 구조 설계까지도 AI가 할 수 있습니다.
그리고 구조 설계를 한다는 것 자체가 이제 아키텍처이기도 하고요.
근데 여전히도 이제 사람이 해야 될 일 중에
이제 남은 한 가지를 꼽으라고 하면 저는 아키텍처 설계라고 생각합니다.
이것도 좀 자신이 없는 이유가 워낙 잘 만들기 때문인데요.
그런데 이제 그런 구상을 사람이 하는 것과
무조건 다 이해에게 맡긴 것과의 결과물.
특히 이제 유지 보수, 운영, 확장성 이런 걸 고려해 볼 때
저는 충분히 이제 알 필요가 있고 알아 두면 매우 좋겠다 라는 영역이 아키텍처입니다.
개발자는 사실 AI 시대에 좀 전에도 약간의 한계성이 좀 있었어요.
그래서 아키텍처를 좀 염두하고 일을 하는 편이었고
또 시니어 개발자가 되다 보면은 결국 아키텍처를 설계하는 역할로 이제 많이 하게 되죠.
그래서 간단히 한번 아키텍처 얘기를 드려보도록 하겠습니다.
뭐 아키텍처라는 단어 갖는 의미 중에는
그냥 뭐 건축물의 모양 이런 것도 한 아키텍처일 수 있고요.
그러니까 시스템을 어떤 식으로 구성할 것이냐라는 측면으로 좀 크게
계락적으로 얘기 드릴 수 있는 것이 아키텍처이고요.
소프트웨어적인 아키텍처도 있고 뭐 하디오를 비롯해서 인프라적인 아키텍처도 있습니다.
시스템 아키텍처도 있고요.
결국 설계에 가장 가까운 것이 아키텍처라고 보시면 되고요.
대표적으로 인프라에서 특히 IT에서 서버
그리고 이제 클라이언트
요렇게 있을 때 이렇게 클라이언트가 서버를 접수하고 서버에서 응답을 해준
요런 것도 일종의 아키텍처입니다.
물론 그 전에는 뭐 하나의 서버에 아주 쓴 클라이언트라든가
뭐 단말만 붙는 수준.
그런데 지금 뭐 클라이언트가 그 정도 수준이 아니에요.
예전으로 치면 지금 핸드폰들은 거의 서버급일 수도 있어요.
아주 예전에.
제가 일기가 메모리가 굉장히 크다고 했던 시절에도 서버 개발을 했었던 적이 있어가지고
용량의 문제가 아니라 어쨌든 클라이언트에서 많은 기능들이 한다.
그래서 서버로 접속을 하고 서버에서 응답을 주는 요런 형태들
요런 것도 하나의 아키텍처입니다.
그래서 이렇게 표현을 할 수가 있어요.
클라이언트 서버 아키텍처.
뭐 간단하고 이제 너무 자연스러운 얘기지만
이것 또한 아키텍처이고요.
여기서 조금만 더 가보면 이제 클라이언트가 있고요.
서버가 동일하게 있는데 여기에 뒤에 데이터베이스가 있고요.
요런 것도 자연스럽죠.
몇 차례 얘기를 드렸었고 요런 상황.
이랬을 때 이것을 3티어라는 표현을 많이 씁니다.
사실 그래서 3티어라는 것은 이제는 너무 자연스러운 구성이기도 하고
가장 많이 쓰는 구성이기도 합니다.
여기를 웹 그리고 워스, 디비.
이렇게 기술적으로는 구성을 하고
여기를 각각을 뭐
프리젠테이션 레이어.
그리고 여기 단을 뭐 비즈니스 레이어.
또 여기는 뭐 퍼스던스 레이어.
뭐 말 자체 용어보다는 그냥 무엇을 하는지가 조금 더
관심을 가질 만한 내용이고요.
여기서 어쨌든 화면.
화면.
그리고 워스 딴.
일단 여기는 뭐 비즈니스로 직.
그리고 디비는 데이터에 저장.
뭐 퍼스던스라고 하면 뭐 연구적인 뭐 그런 의미잖아요.
데이터가 저장된다 해서 이렇게 각각을 기능적으로 좀 묶는 거죠.
그런 식으로 이렇게 구성하는 거 가장 많이 쓰여지고
요즘도 가장 많이 쓴다라고 볼 수 있습니다.
이렇게 3티어로 하는 것이 아키텍처의 일종이고
가장 많이 쓰이는 일반적인 그런 구성이다.
웹 서버도 사실은 서버에 있어요.
서버에 웹 서버가 있고 워스 서버가 있는 거죠.
디비 서버도 있는 거고요.
다 서버 단의 얘기이긴 한데
웹이 갖는 것 중에 화면을 처리해주는 부분이 있잖아요.
html, css, javascript 이런 것들이 화면 역할을 하기 때문에
이렇게 나오는 거고
어쨌든 이게 화면.
그러니까 프레젠테이션을 주로 처리하는 영역
그리고 서버에 어떤 로직들 그런 것들이 담기는 부분
그리고 뭐 데이터 처리.
이렇게 구성이 된다라는 거고요.
이게 대부분 on promise 서버들은
대부분 이렇게 구성을 하는 것 같긴 해요.
물론 이제 이런 것들을 다 아키텍처라고 할 수 있는데
워스만 있는 게 아니라
미드로이어 중에는 캐시 서버 이런 것도 있을 수 있고요.
그리고 msa 아키텍처까지 가면
여기에 중간에 메시지 큐 이런 것도 들어갈 수 있어요.
그래서 msa까지 살짝 이해를 해보면
마이크로 서비스 아키텍처이고요.
마이크로 서비스라는 것은 아주 큰 대규모
하나로 되어 있는 모놀릭이라고 하는데
그런 시스템을 여러 개로 나눈다라는 관점입니다.
이렇게 나눠서 각각을 다소 독립적으로
수행될 수 있게끔 하는 거죠.
이런 사상이 msa예요.
msa의 ms가 마이크로 서비스예요.
좀 작게 쪼갠다.
이것도 하나의 아키텍처라는 거예요.
이것도 하나의 아키텍처고.
근데 msa가 저는 항상 강조하고
얘기하는 거지만 능사는 아니라 생각해요.
그래서 사실은 이렇게 시스템적인 아키텍처는
3 tier만으로도 충분히 서비스를 구성을 할 수가 있습니다.
다만 대규모 서비스를 운영하는 곳은
대부분 마이크로 서비스 아키텍처로 구성되어 있다고 봐도 돼요.
여기서 만약 클라우드로 가게 되면
조금 더 복잡해지고 많은 활용할 수 있는 것들이
되게 많아집니다.
그래서 아키텍처가 좀 더 중요해지고
그런 것들을 잘 활용하는 것이 필요한데요.
일단 기존의 서버들.
조금 온프라미스라는 표현을 쓰는데
그럼 서버들은 이런 식으로 좀 단순한 구성이었다라고
생각하셔도 되고요.
클라우드로 가면 이제 클라우드가 다음에
영상에 클라우드를 달텐데
클라우드로 가면 서버를 좀 자동으로 늘리거나
그리고 서버리스를 쓰거나
이런 조금 다양한 형태들이 좀 있어요.
그래서 그럴 때 좀 이해해야 되는 구성도 있고요.
마이크로 서비스에서도 이게
하나가 여러 개로 쪼개졌다면
각각을 호출하는 것들을 구성을 해야 될 텐데요.
이때 많이 쓰는 것이 메시지 큐라는 겁니다.
카프카를 제일 많이 쓰는 편인데요.
이렇게 메시지를 넣고
필요한 곳에서 가져다가 수행을 하는
그런 식의 어떤 아키텍셔도 있다 라고
생각하시면 됩니다.
이것도 마찬가지예요.
AI로 뭔가를 개발하고자 하시는 분들이
대략적으로 아키텍셔를 먹으나
이렇게 웹이 있고 아스가 있고
데이터베이스에 데이터가 들어가는구나.
웹스 위에 내가 만들고 있는 프로그램들이
설치되고 동작되는구나라를 아는 상황에서
조금씩 더 발전시켜 나갈 필요가 있다는 거고요.
MSA까지 간다는 것은
트래피도 굉장히 많아지고 사용자도 많아지고
서버를 늘려야 되는데
어떤 식으로 할까라고 생각했을 때
생각해볼 수 있는 구성이고요.
MSA가 능상 아니라고 했던 것은
MSA는 좀 복잡합니다.
운영도 복잡하고 관리도 복잡해요.
그래서 초반에는 이렇게 늘리는 것이 좋습니다.
3티어로 했지만
딱 서버가 3개라는 의미는 아니에요.
서버는 굉장히 많을 수 있어요.
근데 이제 늘려간다라는 관점에서
생각해보면 보통은 웹은
굉장히 빠른 처리를 할 수 있어요.
웹에는 비즈니스루직이 담겨 있지 않습니다.
웹은 이미지나 HTML 같은 파일들을 가지고 있어요.
이미지 파일 또는 HTML 파일.
그렇기 때문에 거의 응답만 해주는 형태예요.
요청하면 응답하고 요청하면 응답하고
옛날에 치면 홈페이지 같은 거죠.
사실 홈페이지는 웹서버만으로 가능합니다.
홈페이지와 지금의 인터넷 서비스들의 차이는 뭘까요?
홈페이지는 단순히 화면에
어떤 텍스트들이 있고
이미지가 올라있고
어떤 정보를 주는 정도로 끝나요.
근데 지금의 웹은 어떠냐면
거의 뭐 거기서 워드도 치고
메일도 보내고 다 할 수 있죠.
그게 워스가 있기 때문이고
데이터베이스가 있기 때문이죠.
그렇을 때 이제 이런 식으로 웹에는
몇 가지 이렇게 파일들을 가지고 있다가
응답해주는 것이 전부이기 때문에
사실 사용률도 높지 않아요.
10% 언더.
근데 워스는 이제 프로그램이 담겨져 있기 때문에
굉장히 많은 CPU를 사용합니다.
그렇기 때문에 늘릴 때
워스 서버만 동일하게
여러 대를 늘릴 수가 있는 거예요.
그리고 여기 여러 개를 호출해줄 수 있는
그러니까 무조건적으로 사용량이 많아진다고 해서
MSA로 간다.
저는 이렇게 보지도 않습니다.
굉장히 복잡해지는 구조고요.
초반에는 아니 많이
유입이 돼도
많이 는다면
기본적으로는 서버에 용량을 늘릴 수도 있고요.
아니면 이렇게 동일한 워스를 여러 대를 두고
앞에서 분산을 해줄 수도 있습니다.
이런 모든 것이 다 아키텍처라고 보시면 돼요.
건축물을 어떻게 질까 몇 층으로 질까
그리고 어떻게 올라갈까
이런 모든 구상이 다 아키텍처라고 하면
마찬가지로 이렇게 서버들을 어떻게 배치를 할까
어디랑 어디랑 연결할까
이런 모든 것들 또한 아키텍처라고 보시면 됩니다.
그래서
일단 개념적으로 이러한 것들이 많이 쓰고
이런 구조다라는 것 정도를 이해하시고
다음에 이제 클라우드를 제가 또
영상을 준비할 텐데
이때는 클라우드 상에서의 아키텍처가 조금 더 다양합니다.
그 다양한 아키텍처에 대한 얘기를 이해하실 때
이게 아주 기본적인 골자가 될 겁니다.
제가 그려왔던 아키텍처를 설명하기 위한 구성인데요.
지금 얘기했던 내용들이 좀 포함되어 있습니다.
그래서 기본적으로는 이렇게 어플케이션 만드는 것들
이렇게 어플케션들이
와스에 탑재된다라고 표현을 드렸던
와스의 미드레어에 올라가는 거고
외분, 이미지나 그런 html들 탑재되어 있고요.
그래서 여기 이제 일종의 서버죠.
서버의 어플케션들이 올라가는 형태.
여기가 있고
그다음에 이게 이제 이거는 약간 어플케이션
소프트웨어적인 측면이고
하디오적으로는 실제 서버에
이게 구동되죠.
서버는 컴퓨터예요.
아주 사용이 좋은 컴퓨터들.
서버에 구성이 되는 거고
이 서버들은
서로 간의 네트워크를 통해서 통신을 하고 있다.
이게 어플케션들, 앱들.
이 프로토콜이 주로 htp
이렇게 해가지고 접속이 되어지는 거고
여기에 서버가 있고
서버 위에는 프로램들이 구동된다.
서버 프로램들.
여기에 뭐 데이터베이스도 구동이 될 수 있는 거고
왓스도 있는 거고 웹도 있는 거죠.
왓스에는 우리가 만드는
프로램들이 탑재가 되는 거고요.
그런 아주 기본적인 이런 형태를
아이틴 프라 아키텍처라고 할 수가 있고요.
이 서버 간에 서로 많은
통신들이 또 외부와 연결될 수도 있어요.
외부 서버와.
그래서 어떤 식으로 서버를 구성할까.
왓스는 몇 대로 구성할까.
어떤 역할을 할까.
그 기능들도 나눌 수가 있는 거고요.
그래서 이런 식으로 서버를 어떤 식으로
구성할지에 대한 얘기가
이제 인프라 아키텍처에 대한 내용이 되겠습니다.
어 요번에 좀 간단했는데요.
외버스 디비가 대표적이기도 하고
지금도 많이 쓰이기 때문에
이렇게 말씀을 드린 거고
다만 이제 ai를 도구를 쓰더라도
조금 개발을 잘 해주죠.
하지만 이런 식으로 전체 구조는 좀
알고
이런 작업을 하는 것이 맞고
형원이 유지보스에 있어서도
꼭 알 필요가 있다라고
강조를 드리고 싶습니다.
또 좋은 내용으로 찾아뵙겠습니다.
감사합니다.